My usual bandian botanicals bulk turmeric is not available at the moment by a
aerobatic friend recommended it to me because she says you have to be careful
about the lead in the purple products. Do you know if the
star west botanicals brand on an Amazon is any good?
It says not irradiated too. If I went with pills instead, what dose would you
recommend to replace two tablespoons of ground turmeric? The brands I was
considered were India organic, curcuclear, premium,
research, PRL brand has a ground turmeric but it's very
pricey. Yeah, well any of the firms that you buy can be contaminated.
The benefit of buying from a good supplement company is they test all their
their core products, you know, and India organic India, I think they do a good job
testing, premium research, she's very anal, they're testing
the curcuclear is a design for health product that they're very anal with their
testing too. Excuse me. So going with a good quality
supplement company you know you're going to get a free
test and it's not going to have any garbage and you don't have to worry about it
but you pay for it so it is going to be more expensive.
How much what is the milligram dosage of two tablespoons of ground turmeric?
I don't know. You might be able to find that information on Google but I don't
I don't know what the answer to that is.
I don't know and I don't know if Star West Botanicals
is a good product or not, but can see if it's organic.
I don't know how well they test their stuff.
I wish I had a better answer for you.